قال وزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن
عبد الرحمن الثاني ان دوله قطر لا تعمل
على تاسيس الطاقه ابدا وترى ضروره حمايه
الغذاء والدواء والطاقه لانها قضايا تتعلق
بالناس لا بالحكومات واضاف في تصريحات
خلال منتدى دافوس ان دوله قطر ستكون جاهزه
بحلول عام 2017
بقدرات اضافيه لضغط الغاز الى السوق
العالميه ولا سينما الى القاره الاوروبيه
واضاف ان كثيرا من صناعي سياسات الانتقال
من الطاقه الاحفوريه الى طاقه نظيفه اوقفه
الاستثمار في مصادر الطاقه التقليديه خلال
السنوات الماضيه وتجاهلوا ان هذا الانتقال
يستغرق وقتا اطفال
تويتر
في الطاقه الذي لم تتبعه دوله قطر لحسن
الحظ واتبعته دول اخرى
مكاننا من قدرات اضافيه ستكون جاهزه في
عام 2027 حتى نضخ المزيد من الغازي للسوق
وخاصه الى اوروبا التي تعمل على تنويع
مصادرها نحن نؤمن ان مزيجا من الطاقه
الاحفوريه والطاقه النظيفه مهم جدا مع اخذ
اهميه الغاز بعين الاعتبار والىء الاهميه
اللازمه للمصادر الاخرى للطاقه الى ان
نحقق اهدافنا